just because you can execute a program
on the computer to perform a task does
not mean that the system you've created
understands the task
the taste of the last orange you write
do you remember the warmth of that
welcoming group of tea that you had when
you came in from the cold November rain
do you remember
smell
of the hair
of the first love that you kissed I'd
like you to try and hold on to these
Sensations because I'm going to come
back to them
[Music]
in our culture there's a big deal about
objectivity and subjectivity we strive
for an objective science the problem is
that these Notions are systematically
ambiguous in a way that produces
intellectual catastrophes they're
ambiguous between a sense which is
epistemic where epistemic means having
to do with knowledge
epistemic
and a sense which is ontological
where ontological means having to do
with existence I hate using a lot of
fancy polysyllabic words and I'll try to
get into a minimum but I need these two
epistemic and ontological
now the problem with objectivity and
subjectivity
is that they're systematically ambiguous
between an epistemic sense
I'll just abbreviate subjectivity
between an epistemic sense and an
autological sense
epistemically the distinction is between
types of knowledge claims if I say uh
Rembrandt died in 1606 well no he didn't
die that he was born in I say Rembrandt
was born in 1606 that is to say it's a
matter of objective fact that's
epistemically cot injected but if I say
Rembrandt is the greatest painter that
ever lived well that's a matter of
opinion that is epistemically subject
okay so you have epistemic objectivity
and subjectivity underlying that is a
distinction in modes of existence lots
of things exist regardless of anybody
what anybody thinks mountains molecules
and tectonic plates have a mode of
existence that's ontologically objective
but pains and tickles and itches they
all exist and so far as they are
experienced by a subject they are
ontologically subjecting descriptive
knowledge or knowing what is knowledge
of particular facts as potentially
expressed by our theories Concepts and
ideas
you may remember on mlst when we Define
knowledge as a Justified true belief
this means that the belief must be
established or proven the Justified true
belief account of knowledge is the claim
that knowledge can be conceptually
analyzed which is to say the meaning of
sentences such as I know that I am
employed can be given with the following
set of conditions which are necessary
and sufficient for it to be designated
as knowledge
a subject knows that a proposition is
true if and only if the proposition is
true and the subject believes that the
proposition is true and finally that the
subject is Justified in believing that
the proposition is true now this account
was first credited to Plato even though
Plato himself later argued against this
account of knowledge
now you may have heard of the gettier
problem which is the problem of
identifying which justification is
needed in order for a belief to count as
knowledge
some philosophers attempt to solve the
gettier problem by adding a fourth
condition to the three conditions
mentioned above While others attempt to
solve it by either replacing or refining
the justification condition
now you often hear us talking about
syntax versus semantics on mlst and this
is the core story of today's episode
this is what soul is talking about here
how do things which exist in the world
map to our knowledge and thus our
understanding of them
when we talk about artificial
intelligence what we basically mean
is the science and engineering we're
trying to engineer machines to do things
that we might say is clever
Souls Minds brains and programs paper
argued that minds are not the same as
brains and that programs are not the
same as mines he argued that the mind is
not a computer program
and the brain is not a computer
in 1994 John Searles stated that the
Chinese room argument is an attempt to
prove the truth of the following premise
that syntax is not sufficient for
semantics and that programs are formal
and Minds have content
this led him to the conclusion that
programs are not minds and hence that
computationalism the idea that the
essence of thinking lies in
computational processes and such
processes thereby underlie and explain
conscious thinking is false okay well to
get a handle on the Chinese room it's
really important to be aware of the
context and the time that Soul came up
with the thought experiment he primarily
was on a flight going to spend some time
in the labs of shank and Abelson who
around in the late 70s had published a
well received book called Scripps goals
and understanding if I remember I think
um where they described how they could
engineer computational systems that
could take as input a simple story I'm
not talking about war and Priests or the
Bible but something along the lines of
Jack and Jill went up the hill to fetch
a pile of water
and they could take
questions about that story like who went
up the hill why did Jack go up the hill
and it the systems using What's called
the script and here I don't I neither
mean a script as in a theater script or
a script as in a a mode of writing but I
mean in the technical computational
way of a set of expectations unfolding
over time
to to and pick that a little
I like to use the metaphor of a
restaurant script
a script for me going to restaurant
would be might be something like
um I choose a restaurant to go to
uh I walked to the restaurant I looked
for the door I open the door I walk into
the restaurant I look for the maitre d I
asked to be seated at a table I expect
them that made the waiter to give me a
menu I choose some drinks I choose a
meal I eat the meal I look I get my bill
and then I pay and I leave now given a
set of expectations such as that I
script about restaurants I can give you
a story that said Mark went to a
restaurant he chose vegetarian lasagna
which was priced at 10 pounds he left 12
pounds and he left and then shank system
would be able to answer questions of did
Mark enjoy his mail and it would say yes
because he left a check it would work
out that they'd left the tip and you in
the script about restaurants you leave
tibs if you enjoy your meal so shank
system using this primitive notion of
scripts was able to answer not just
simple questions about who went into the
restaurant Mark did but given a little
story it could infer facts that were not
explicit in that story
and not shank and Ableton but I did
always the case some of the more
excitable post grads and Ras who are
working in their lab began to make
fairly strong claims about these systems
that here we have for the first time
computers that really understand and so
thought these claims so bizarre that he
came up with the Chinese room thought
experiment that he thought disproved the
notion firstly that shank enables and
systems understood but then when cat
when Saul carefully wrote this up in his
paper Minds Brands and programs and very
subtly makes clear his argument doesn't
just apply to an approach such as that
that shank and abelson's uh described
and which cell explicitly Targets in the
paper that of scripts stories and
questions about stories but it applies
to any computational technology
whatsoever any computational formalism
he argues that the Chinese film shows
that computation is not sufficient to
Grant systems intentionality or Genuine
understanding so that's the backdrop to
to the scenario so how did this pan out
well so imagine that he was
um positioned in a room that had to be
in China
and um
in this room he notices three piles of
papers
and on these papers are strange
squiggles and squiggles you've got no
idea what they are
um he doesn't even know that they're
Chinese idiographs are distinct from
Japanese idiographs as distinct to
drawings of your child might have made
the dead just squiggles and
uninterpreted squiggles and squiggles
also in the room is a large book full of
rules and these rules tell him how to
how to match purely by their form
one set of squiggles with another set of
squiggles and so they'll match squirrels
in the first pile with squiggles in the
second they'll correlate squiggles in
the first two piles which Wiggles in the
third and other rules will tell him what
squiggles and squiggles
to slot through a hole in the door
letterbox in the door people in the
outside world
so sir because he's got nothing else to
do starts following this rule but
manipulating squiggles and squirrels to
his heart's content occasionally putting
Bits of Paper out through the door until
the process terminates now unbeknownst
to sell the first pile of papers
contained a script the second part of
the papers contained a story in Chinese
and the third are the papers contained
questions about that story in Chinese
and the Bits of Paper cell was passing
to people through the slot in the door
were answers to those questions in the
story now because the Chinese rule
writers or programmers as we might call
them were very very good
the answers that sell past to people
outside the room were indistinguishable
from those a native Chinese person might
give so if the story was Jack and Jill
went up the hill to get a pound of the
water and one of the questions was who
went up the hill so would give the
idiograss for Jack and Jill went up the
hill which were exactly the same as
those are genuine Chinese person would
like why did Jack go up the hill then
give that the idographs together pay the
water exactly the same now the people
outside the room had no idea what was
going on in the room all they knew is
that they'd previously they'd been told
the story and they'd file the seven
questions about this story and some time
later out threw a slot in the door they
were getting beautiful answers to their
questions that were indistinguishable
and there was a native Chinese person
would have made
so from the external perspective it
appeared that the Chinese room was
understand that the room was
understanding Chinese stories and yet
cell transably insisted that he still
didn't understand the word of Chinese in
fact he had no idea he was either
responding in Chinese to anything that
he was responding to questions about
stories or indeed that there was even a
story involved all he was doing was
formal symbol manipulation uninterpreted
simple manipulation
and so this then so this story is
initially cast to map on to be
isomorphic to the situation described by
shank and Abelson so you have the notion
of the script the story and questions
about the story but by extension cells
as we can reconceptualize this well the
rule book is any computer program that
you like
um and that cell just follows the rules
using Bits of Paper to write as
variables to write down intermediate
values of calculations you might need to
make and eventually putting symbols out
through the uh um through the letterbox
to the outside world about anything
um and uh he can still do that and not
having as long as he's just doing formal
symbol manipulation uninterpreted symbol
manipulation he's not understanding a
thing about what he's doing
Steve Harnett argued that Soul's true
scone was for functionalism and
computationalism he argued that
Consciousness can be defined as a set of
informational processes inside the brain
and it follows that anything which
carried out the same informational
processes as a human is also conscious
thus if humans wrote a computer program
that was conscious they could run that
computer program on say a system of ping
pong balls or beer cuts and the system
would be equally conscious because it
was running the same informational
processes
sir argued that this is impossible since
Consciousness is a physical property
like digestion or fire no matter how
good a simulation of digestion is built
on a computer it won't digest anything
and no matter how well it simulates fire
nothing will be burned by contrast
informational processes are Observer
relative observers pick out certain
patterns in the world and consider them
informational processes but
informational processes are not things
in the world themselves since they do
not exist at a physical level
sir argues they cannot have causal
efficacy and thus cannot cause
consciousness
so there's no physical law certainly
insists they can see an equivalence
between a personal computer a series of
ping pong balls and beer cans and pipe
and Water Systems all implementing the
same program
I had a conversation with Francois
sholay from the Google brain team he is
without a doubt one of my heroes of
artificial intelligence he wrote an
influential paper on the measure of
intelligence which Yannick and I have
made about eight hours of content on by
now
Francois gave us his take on the Chinese
room argument here you go as humans we
have this tendency to project beliefs
and intentions
like mental models on the things around
us alright that's our theory of mind and
applied to deep learning and that means
that when we're able to
somewhat successfully train a deep
learning model to handle a task that
would normally be performed by a human
then we are led to believe that the Deep
learning model understands what it's
doing that the process going on inside
the model is somehow
um similar to the process going on in
our own minds when we handle the same
problem but in fact deep learning models
are solving a very very different
problem and they are doing so with a
very different Knowledge from the
knowledge that you have
so our own understanding of
images and language comes from our
experience as humans it is grounded in
our experience but deep learning models
have no access to these expense so they
do not really understand their task in
any human relatable way the only thing
they understand is again this this
matting between the the train data to
the Target data so to be clear it is
very good at pattern recognition and I'm
not in any way trying to downplay the
significance of being good at pattern
recognition this is actually immensely
useful the planning is applicable to a
tremendous scope of very difficult and
important problems in motion perception
because they are pattern recognition
problems at heart but importantly deep
learning is not the road to our
artificial general intelligence right
scaling up deep learning by adding more
layers adding architect to your search
using you know these deeper models or
string on more data is not going to get
you to AGI
I see two issues with the Chinese
remarkment so let me explain
the gists are the Chinese room arguments
is that it's a mentally match it's meant
to be useful to think about the
properties that you might see in a
program executing on a computer can a
computer understand what he does can it
be intelligent
and the Chinese room arguments talks
about a man in a room with a book of
thoughts that implements a Chinese
language
but with the setup actually stands for
is a turing machine that executes a
polar the man is a turing machine and
the book is the problem
that's what it's all about so John sir
is saying well a turing machine is
pretty mysterious it's pretty hot reason
so let's choosing about this alternative
mentally imagined stats and by the way I
found this metal image actually
counterparty actively harmful because
if you understand what the computer is
you understand the program is you
understand how the computer executes the
problem then you don't need to come up
with a different mentally managed to
reason of that it only serves to
obfuscates what you're reasoning about
it creates a non-necessary layer of
contribution
anyway what the Chinese room argument is
saying is basically just because a
computer can execute a program to
accomplish a certain task does not mean
that the computer understands the task
and it's actually a correct stage but
not for the reasons that's her arms the
main problem with service argument is
that he's looking at the wrong system
he's looking at the man in the room
executing rules to communicate in
Chinese and he's saying well that man
does not understand Chinese therefore
the rumor support does not understand
Chinese and of course the person
executing the rooms does not understand
Chinese that's not where you would
expect understanding to be located in
the system
understanding is an imagined property of
the information processing system as a
ball
right understanding is not into
instructions themselves it's not in the
processor that executes the instructions
it's the functional dynamics of how the
input information is being processed by
the instructions
so that's a bit abstract so let's look
at the different example
let's look at yourself
you are intelligence that's not a
complemented just a fact you understand
English
but what is this you system that angle
sends English is it and the bloodstream
in your brain you would say no obviously
it's on the bloodstream because it's
only only tangentially related to
information processing
visit your neurons then is it your
connector
well it's not because for instance a few
seconds after you die your neurons and
your connectum are still intact but you
are no longer intelligent in fact you no
longer exist
so what is it there well the use system
that understands English is an emergence
system that arises from the way your
brain processes in this case a language
the functional dynamics of the way your
brain processes information
which is why you only exist the moments
your brain is running if it's not
shrining anymore there are no for sure
Dynamics and so there's no you anymore
so it's not the neurons physically
because they're just a collection of
cells and it's not the way they're
connected either because it's just a
grout and a graph by itself is not
intelligent
it's the way your brain processes
information is this emergence
information processing system that's
capable of understanding
and this information processing system
is independence of wet physical
substrates we choose to include it so if
you recreate your brain perfectly in a
digital medium for instance it would
still have the same functional diamonds
and therefore it will still be the same
system from an information passing
standpoint
in the same way that a story a novel is
independent of the paper and ink that
you use to print it it's still the same
novel if you distribute it as a digital
PDF instead
and if you look at the Chinese room the
system to look at is not the man which
is a metaphor for a CPU and it's called
the book which is a metaphor for a
program it's the functional dynamics of
how the Chinese input information is
being processed by the law by the
instructions executed by the man and
this is not a system
that you can observe it's not a physical
system in the same way that you cannot
observe understanding in the brain you
can observe brain activities in
particularly observe understanding or
near the way you can observe physical
book but you cannot observe the story
content in that book the story is
something that emerges in your mind as
you read the book
the story is something which emerges in
your mind as you read the book
just think about that for a minute
here's another way to get it
let's say I come out with a program that
simulates the inner workings of your
brain perfect every single cell
simulated it and then I also stimulates
your body and your environment and then
I run the simulation and computer
well the virtual you in that simulation
behaves exactly natural in every way so
anyone interacting with that virtually
would say definitely that you attribute
is intelligent
and you know if you zoom out and you ask
well where his intelligence located in
that system
is it located in a CPU of the computer
that runs the simulation no there's just
a plain old CPU in a broadly executing
one instruction after another just like
the man in the Chinese room
so is it the program of the simulation
let's intelligent then well no I mean
that's just a bunch of C plus plus files
on disk it's no more intelligent than
the rulebook in the Chinese run
the system that's actual intelligence in
this metaphor is the imagined system
that arises from actually running the
simulation it's the way the simulated
brain processes information in the
simulation that constitutes intelligence
that's where understanding is so
understanding emerges from information
processing but it's not present from the
individual physical components that are
used to implement this potassium it's
not present in the CPU in particular
because it's just a little bit of
silicon the same way your neurons are
just a bunch of sets and all these
components by the way are expendable you
can replace them with other equivalent
components as long as they are
functional lengths remain the same
and that's why if you look at the man in
the Chinese room and you point out that
the man does not understand Chinese
you're completely missing the point of
course the CPU doesn't understand what
it's doing that's not some kind of
subtle insight
and that's actually completely honest
you're looking at the wrong system
saying that the CPU doesn't understand
what it's doing is not sufficient to
tell whether the information processing
system understands what it's doing for
not
but it doesn't seem to have answered so
far there's an answer from certain
wealth where he says oh so you think I'm
not doing the right system well hanba
did let's say instead of a rulebook the
man memorizes the Wolves and executes
the rules from memory well if you do
that the man becomes a perfectly
self-contained system so it should be
obvious that the man uses this system
right
therefore if the man does not understand
Chinese then the Chinese room does not
instant chance right
and to me the fact that he would come up
with these counter arguments reveals a
profound constitution of ideas because
the change that he proposes of getting
rid of the book and including the rules
in different medium that does not affect
the information processing system at all
so sir appears to say that when defines
the system to him
is a physical boundary like the
thermodynamics and that's completely out
so here's an example let's say you have
a desktop computer
and you have an external GPU plugged
into that desktop
so next you decide when that's not
convenient so you include the GPU
directly inside the desktop case did
that change anything about the way your
computer processes information
no you didn't change the information
processing system at all you changed
your computer as a physical system at
the thermodynamic system but not as an
information processing system
and in the Chinese room it doesn't
matter if the rules are encoded in a
book or it's there in a PDF file on a
Kindle or it's there on the VHS tag or
if they are memorized by the map and it
also doesn't matter if she replaced a
man with a trained monkey or with a
turing machine that does not change the
information passing system at all it
does not change anything that matters
about your system so I think what's
going on with certain is that he
conscious is the information about the
system which is what you should care
about and the encoding substrates the
physical substrates and used by that
system it's kind of countries in the
mind and the neurons or confusing a
physical book and the story contained in
it
and the second thing I want to say about
the change from arguments it's about why
the Chinese room does not in fact
understand Chinese because I agree with
sir on that it has nothing to do with
the fact that the man in the Chinese
room doesn't understand Chinese so even
if she look at the right system you look
at the information processing system
implemented by the Chinese one that
system still does not end sanctions
here's why
durables in the Chinese room is a
program
it's what I call a crystallized skill
Poland and by executing this program you
implement is killing so for instance
turning a Chinese input into an
appropriate Chinese output to to hold
the conversation
with that program since it's just a
bunch of rules written in the book it's
got to be purely static it cannot learn
it connected new worlds for instance it
cannot adapt to things that aren't part
of the self inputs constipated by the
creators of the rulebook so it cannot
pick up new skills on your knowledge
about the world and if you try to teach
it German for instance well it's done in
the award to learn German
so it wouldn't actually be able to pass
a Turing test for this reason because to
be able to pass the sharing test for Ryu
you're going to need two depth you are
going to need learning abilities and
that's why it's not actually intention
that's why it doesn't understand what
it's doing in the same way that
a chess playing program like deep blue
doesn't understand with chesses
so skill at the task is not sufficient
to assert understanding of the task skit
is not what defines understanding or
intelligence
intelligence is characterized by the
ability to learn and adapt and
efficiently pick up new skills from
experience the skill itself is not
intelligence skill is the outputs of
intelligence it is a skill acquisition
that characterizes intelligence in
pascular's skill acquisition efficiency
intelligence is a process that produces
skill problems like the rulebook in the
room but a skill program itself is not
intelligent it's the output artifacts
after the process of intelligence
if you understand what you're doing then
you can adapt what you're doing when the
world changes you can learn and adapt
and improve and if you don't understand
what you're doing then you're stuck with
a static skill and that's really how you
tell the difference between
understanding and not understanding
but you know what Dairy is actually
intelligence somewhere in this story
because someone had to write the Chinese
rulebook and the entity that wrote the
book did understand Chinese
and that's why the way I would write a
book in the first place so if Chinese as
a language evolves over the next 10
years where it gains new worlds
um and so on when that entity should be
able to go back and update the book
that's how you can tell with this entity
understands Chinese
if you zoom out she noticed that the
confusion between scale and skill
acquisition ability also known as
intelligence is one of the most
fundamental most harmful
misunderstandings in the Philadelphia
so there isn't the information
processing system in the Chinese room is
not understand Chinese is because it's
purely a static skill program it has
nothing to do with the fact that the
role executor the man in the room does
not understand Chinese
that's why the point that sir was making
is technically correct that just because
you can't execute a program on a
computer to perform a task does not mean
that the system you've created
understands the paths that point is
correct but not for the reasons the
child is and the more General point that
Sarah was making which is that a
computer cannot be intelligent cannot
show understanding where that point is
hopelessly or
surely seems to be addressing the
structure of the thought experiment
itself as opposed to the underlying
epistemic principle that it's trying to
illustrate
he confused me a little bit because he's
conflating intelligence and
understanding I've studied Francois work
on intelligence in great detail and I
wholeheartedly agree with his
mathematically abstract premise that it
entails the efficient systemic creation
of flexible skill programs from
empirical data and existing priors but I
don't think the Chinese Rim argument has
anything to do with intelligence and
everything to do as semantics
semantics is about the interpretation of
your mapping to an inner structure to
assign meaning whether it's subjective
or not
understanding means finding the correct
semantic mapping thus ascertaining
meaning by reconstructing the
intentional with an S structure in
another person's mind
now remember the intentional structure
is an infinite object right the miracle
of human cognition is that we can
disambiguate the meaning from this
infinite set of possible mappings I
don't think it's got anything to do with
intelligence right the mappings can be
crystallized now I'm going to give
Charlotte the benefit of the doubt I
think what he actually means by
conflating them is that in order to
reapply the knowledge that you
understood in a new situation then you
would need intelligence the more
intelligence you have then the larger
the frame of reference or as Chalet
would say the larger the space of of
experiences in which that knowledge
could be applied
now I think in chalet's framework
knowledge is just crystallized prior as
an experience
cell meant that intentionality is a
special physical property which is
present in organic systems rather than
what Chalet believes namely that it's a
functional emergent property of dynamic
effects in the process of Agents systems
and their constituents interacting with
environments and you know even including
interacting with with other actors
now um Bishop on the other hand I
believe is getting to the root of Soul's
argument he's pointing out something
different he's pointing out the
ontological difference which is to say
the difference in existence and subject
of experience in the understanding of so
in the room the difference between
phenomenal experience and its absence
you can see by now a lot of
computationalists including Charmers
himself Escape Mark's argument through
the argument of functionalism or
arguments based on functionalism
now functionalism is the doctrine that
what makes something a thought or a
desire or a pain or any other type of
mental state depends not on its internal
Constitution but solely on its function
or the role it plays in the cognitive
system of which it is apart
now functionalist theories take the
identity of a mental state to be
determined by its causal relations to
sensory stimulations other mental States
and behavior in plain English this means
that a computer program with the correct
internal states which meet these
conditions would be capable of
experiencing pain or any other
subjective phenomena
what about
um structuralist computationalism well
Charmers actually goes one step further
Chalmers is not only a functionalist but
a structuralist computationalist he
thinks that the causal structure
described by a computational model is
what distinguishes one mental state from
another this is the thesis that Chalmers
would later develop in depth from about
1995 or so and it's based on the work of
Hillary Putnam who started doing it in
around 1967. anyway according to this
Theory a computational model is
implemented in a physical system if and
only if the causal structure of the
model is isomorphic to the formal
structure of the physical system
um one of my questions actually was to
ask you to Define intelligence but um
just before we get there I'm interested
to know do you think intelligence and
Consciousness are orthogonal or
entangled I mean which is to say do you
think it's possible to implement one
without the other
I think they're totally entangled in
practice I think they're conceptually
distinct though the concept of
intelligence is at least for me the
concept of certain kinds of you know
very sophisticated Behavior being able
to achieve a wide range of goals
in a wide range of environments that's
basically tied to behavior whereas
Consciousness is the concept of
Consciousness is subjective and tied to
first-person experience so the concepts
are distinct but I think empirically
they're very much entangled you know the
best example of Consciousness we have is
the human being which is also the best
example of intelligence that we have so
it looks like there's at least some
and most people think that uh as you say
go
um you know on The evolutionary tree go
down to preachers with less intelligence
you're probably also going to have to
some extent less Consciousness so most
people think that dogs
uh you know dogs are intelligent but not
as intelligent as humans and most people
are inclined to think they're probably
conscious but their Consciousness is not
as rich as humans but that said there
may be some beings which are extremely
intelligent in some ways gpg3 may be an
example but it's just set up in such a
way that it has rather little
in the way of Consciousness and the
maybe beings very simple systems that
can say at least be very conscious in
the sense of say feeling very intense
pain but they don't have a lot of
uh intelligence capacity so I think the
two can probably come apart but our best
theories of Consciousness I think tend
to tie it to complex information
processing
our best Theories of Intelligence also
tie it to complex information processing
maybe the kinds of information
processing relevant to Consciousness are
not exactly the same as those relevant
to intelligence but I think there's
pretty good reason to think that they're
strongly correlated this is Dr Joshua
Bach on Consciousness I mean you said
actually that you've spent much of your
life thinking about what Consciousness
is and um you said that you you thought
it was very mysterious but you now think
that it's a riddle that can be uh solved
right so on your recent Theory of
Everything interview with Donald Hoffman
actually you said that it was virtual
not a physical thing that brains are
mechanistic and that the elements of
Consciousness are magical somehow but
you said it had an a causal structure
but not the way physics is built but it
was a story which the physical system
tells to itself you said that the
organism is a coherent and consistent
pattern
which is State Building at least at some
level of analysis and that Consciousness
allows organisms to coordinate
themselves to succeed in their niches
and then you spoke of information
processing over cells now what model of
I should say like what measure of
Consciousness do you think you most
align with
and there's only one theory that offers
a measure of Consciousness and there's
this integrated information Theory
whereas you actually put a number on it
and it's not clear what that number
means it's not that there is some kind
of scalar that measures this and and
people we think of Consciousness as
something that is more qualitative than
quantitative either somebody is
conscious or somebody is unconscious and
when you are conscious you can have a
lack of Acuity you can be adult in your
brain and you can be drifting in and out
of Consciousness but uh it's still a
qualitative thing of whether you have
that or not and this qualitative thing
seems to be simple
it's probably much simpler that people
expect it to be
the hard thing might be perception
and Consciousness is on top of
perception as a certain way to deal with
our attention so I think a very
important aspect of Consciousness is
reflexive attention that we notice
ourselves attending to something and we
reflect on that and integrate this in
our model
the conundrum was understanding
Consciousness a few go right into the
history of everything striking these
lightness and many others leibniz says
this idea of imagine you could have a
Mill and uh this this is your mind and
this animal is made of lots of
mechanical parts and somehow the thing
is feeling and perceiving things and we
blow the middle up so large that we can
walk into great with today they may zoom
into it until we see all the parts and
we just see this pushing and pulling
parts and nothing of them can ever
explain perception or a Feeling
and this is a very strong intuition that
also drives the Chinese room and many
other uh thinkers who get attracted to
this and it seems pretty obvious that
these mechanical phenomena are
insufficient to explain what's going on
it's not an obvious connection so people
become dualists the Samoa are two
completely separate domains and I think
in a way this dualism is correct but not
in the sense that the metal states are
ontologically existing
they are exist as if
there is no organism there is only this
connection of cells in this collection
of cells is acting in a coherent way
which means we can compress it we can
model it using a very low dimensionals
much simpler function then look at all
the cells in general and the organism is
only approximating this function but
what makes the organism more powerful
than the collection of cells is exactly
that function the structure that we
project into it and the interesting
thing is that by the information
processing within the organism the
organism can discover that function by
itself and use it to drive its own
behavior
so while the organism is not a person
it's not even an organism it is very
useful for the organism to behave it if
it was an organism
and also to have an idea what it would
be like to be a person that interacts
friends with the social world
so it creates a simulation of that it's
often not even a simulation it's often
just a symbolacrum that's what makes it
a causal the difference between the
simulation and the reality is that the
simulation is modeling some aspects of
the Dynamics of a domain on a different
causal substrate on the different causal
footing so you have a computer game in
which you can shoot a gun but there is
no proper physics in the game that would
recreate what's happened in real world
when you shoot the gun right instead it
is using a different causal structure of
your software program to give you
something that gives you good enough
Dynamics so you can interact with the
world and experience this causal
structures you can make a different
decision you make a different move with
the game and as a result the game
behaves as if you would expect it
because it's imitating the same causal
structure using this different substrate
in a similar room you don't have the
causal structure like a movie doesn't
have causal structure it only gives you
a sequence of observables an overall
mental model of osr elves is a mixture
of simulation and simulacrum
so right we sometimes create a sequence
without causal structure it looks like
it does this thing magically and
sometimes we have a causal model but
this causal model is not the real deal
it's just this simplified geometric
simulation of how the world works at
game engines that our brain is producing
to anticipate what happens in the
physical world
[Music]
1988 the influential American
philosopher Hillary Putnam
published a paper in which he showed
that under the influence of
gravitational waves and cosmic rays
the subatomic particles that make up all
the objects of our world
your seat the seat is sitting on
the very clothes you're wearing the room
that we're in
they're all containing a rich dance of
subatomic particles a dance that never
repeats itself and putting them realized
that this is analogous
to a state machine going through an
infinite series of non-repeating states
so it then seems to me that if
a computer a Terminator perhaps is
conscious purely as a result of moving
through a series of computational State
transitions then if I know the input to
that machine with input fixed I can
generate exactly the same series of
State transitions with any large counter
like a car's myelometer or following
Hillary putnam's move with any open
physical system so if a machine is
conscious smoothie as a result of
following some computation then
Consciousness is everywhere
in the bricks of this building the
clothes that you're wearing the very
seat you're sitting on they are all
experiencing The Zing of that orange
the warmth of that cup of tea
and the memory of your first little kiss
machine Consciousness is possible
everything even the smallest grain of
sand is filled with an infinitude of
conscious experiences
[Music]
I'm uh Professor Mark Bishop until
recently I worked at Goldsmith's
University of London
latterly running a center in intelligent
data analytics
which was kind of an unusual academic
center and that it was completely
commercially funded
so one of my jobs as director was always
to be looking for the next project to
feed the pipeline because if we had no
jobs in the pipeline
everybody was made redundant in the
center closed so it was quite a high
pressure job both getting in liaising
with industry getting interesting new
projects and then recruiting and
maintaining a team to use AI to help
deliver on those projects
um prior to taking up that role I was
professor of cognitive Computing at
goldsmiths where I run an MSC in College
of computing
um which tried to embrace and take
seriously modern approaches to cognitive
science in a way that most constant
Computing mscs that I was aware of our
competitor degrees were very heavily
traditionally based I tried because of
my own research interests to look into
into more alternative approaches to
cognitive science and cognitive
computing
before moving to goldsmiths I was on the
faculty of the cybernetics department at
the University of reading where our head
of Department most of the time was a guy
called Professor Kevin Warwick and
amusingly Kevin and I had totally
different views on on artificial
intelligence Kevin was very positive
about what can be achieved by
computation and in fact when the
department built these small robots a
third of them and we called the Seven
Dwarfs that had very small neural
networks a few hundred neurons and that
could be switched on with a table Raza
in spare quotes and then through
interactions with their environment
learned to move around as rapidly as
they could and not rub into each other
when they'd learned to do that Kevin was
used to say to me it's purely human bias
if you don't give these things the same
conscious States as as biological
systems of the same complexity and he
pointed to some species of slugs
and interesting that was one of the
moves that got me interested in in
thinking about machine Consciousness
because it seemed to me
that it's a category error to say of
these robots that they were conscious at
all there were no more conscious to me
than a brick so then began an
intellectual Adventure that finally led
to the development of the dancing with
Pixies reductor on Adam certain where I
tried to show that if it's the case that
Kevin's robots really are conscious as
they moved around their Chorale then a
vicious form of pansakism is entailed
whereby every open system
I can experience every conceivable
phenomenal experience and that seems to
me farcical so and then led to reject
the Horn of the reductio and reject the
claim that computation can give rise to
phenomenal consciousness
what really jumps out to me is you
you've made this contribution with the
dancing with Pixies which is essentially
that if strong AI exists then
um a vicious form of pan psychism must
exist but I think actually you're making
the case the CRA case even better than
sold it because when you take into
account this requisite
um phenomenal experience so in order to
understand wetness you have to be wet to
me that's a much better case for the
Chinese room argument
the cells minds and Brands and Paragons
is in my opinion one of an exceptionally
well written paper and
it it merits revisiting there's an awful
lot in it and a lot of the criticisms
that have been leveled against so so
actually answers in the paper if you dig
carefully enough
and
it came to me some time ago I'm
reflecting on the Chinese room and
particularly in reflecting to John
Hogan's critique of the systems reply
um that one of the key differences was
when sir was asked given a joke in
English when he was in the Chinese room
he would have laughed he would have
understood the joke that's a key point
he would have understood the joke and
had the con Comet and phenomenal
sensation of understanding a joke which
is ding I've got the joke and secondly
hahaha my body's laughing in a way that
when he's given a Chinese joke he's not
even aware he's been given a joke and he
certainly has no phenomenal Sensations
attached to him anywhere at all and this
seemed to be a difference in kind and
ontological difference if you like a
difference in being in between so
listening to jokes in English
bringing forth a certain way of being in
a certain state that of laughter and so
acting epistemologically responding to
questions or responding to a joke in
Chinese but without still even knowing
you're too into a joke now ironically if
you reread the Chinese room you can see
that this
sales point is the some of this as Frank
Johnson's concerned some of the major
confusions about the Chinese women have
come from a confusion between
epistemology and ontology which is
exactly what I tried to tease apart with
that example of listening to jokes in
Chinese and in English but I do actually
think to be fair if you read the paper
carefully this is kind of implicit in
what soul actually said I've just tried
to sort of clarify some of the uh some
of the deeper issues that sell actually
wrote in the paper in the first place
and well ironically you you understood
his argument better than anyone else
I guess I had that flash of intuition
that was something it was like to to get
that certainly yeah
so how do Bishops views compared to
people like Francois Chalet and David
Chalmers well they're both emergentists
Bishop from a biological substrate and
Chalet and Chalmers from information
itself and the cause of interactions
between the constituents
the overarching question is really where
does agency and Free Will intentionality
teleology goal-directed Behavior where
does all of this stuff originate because
we have a bit of a chicken and egg
problem for Bishop it's bottom-up he
thinks that life emerges from the
physical properties present in the
microscopic level and their behaviors
which is to say autopiosis and teleology
through the complex interactions between
the
microscopic elements of that system
Chalmers and Chalet think that it's top
down that information gives rise to
Minds Chalmers even going one step
further explicitly calling it strongly
emerging which is to say the phenomena
is more than the sum of its parts with
the intentionality originating in the
macroscopic level kind of top down
so Bishop like Putnam before him will
always counter with the argument that he
could reproduce the computation and
trivial physical substrate like a Carl's
myelometer and it would be bereft of any
agency you know one interesting feature
of Bishop school of thought is that it
still has access to continuous variables
the it from bit or information version
are spelled by Chalmers and Chalet are
limited to the digital world
now I spoke with Keith about this and he
leans more towards continuer being real
and important but he disagrees with
Sterling Bishop he said that Professor
Carl friston is Right suppose that we
did have a machine which could calculate
the same category of hypercomputation
with continuous variables which people
could exist on and experience feelings
and subjective qualia they are states in
that model if we had a continuous
computer Keith said that we could
reproduce everything about human
consciousness
this discussion all boils down to
whether a mind can arise from
information rather than being a property
of physical matter
this is Professor Carl friston
I I think what you're saying if you are
a computationalist is that if we could
recreate all of the stuff that you're
just talking about so forward reasoning
and planning Etc that we could recreate
Consciousness in silicone yes yes I I
see no reason why you couldn't create an
artifact that was sufficiently similar
to you and me
um that would um you know qualify as big
conscious yeah that I am I think I'm I'm
a computationalist as well so suppose um
suppose we did create an in silico you
know chip and some software that that
had the depth of counterfactual planning
of temporal planning that could in fact
evaluate its own actions and could even
evaluate at a metal level you know the
computations that are going into that
that evaluation so the sort of full
stack almost the full recursive stack
there
would that thing because a lot of times
what I read from you know Chalmers or
other others is a question of feeling
like what does it feel like to be
conscious right and so with that thing
in your view feel
like something you know would it have
the qualia of experience that we do yes
but you'd have to write it into the
generative model so you'd have to have
to write the different feeling States as
hypotheses about how my feeling at the
moment and then it would use or I I
would use or you would use
um all the messages and the belief
updating and all the planning and all
the estimates of uncertainty that attend
that planning and that's quite key
actually
um the the the Precision or the
estimates of uncertainty start to take
much much greater uh roles in terms of
the heavy lifting of the belief updating
the higher you get in the hierarchy so
it so I I am feeling in this way
um I am aware of myself
having this quality of experience these
would all be hypotheses
um that were recognized in a good
old-fashioned variational Auto encode
away from everything that's going on
below crucially including interceptive
feelings and States of your battery your
blood sugar and all of that good stuff
um okay so I think if I understand you
correctly and this is this is pretty
cool so the feeling is actually a
knowledge of
a certain you know activity or
trajectory like that is the feeling is
in fact a knowledge
absolutely well you could even say that
the instance of the fate and the
realization of the feeling is the
inference in the context of a a
knowledge structure that just is the
generative model that has
um representations or slots that have a
semantics of I'd feel like a self I feel
unhappy I feel anxious I feel enough you
know whatever whatever it is that is the
best sense making the best hypothesis or
explanation in you know as simple but
not too simple way
um for everything that's going on so
feelings uh including things like paid
and this is a you know this is quite an
important so this is not just a
philosophical nice nicety it really
matters in the treatment of chronic pain
when you're trying to identify the
locusts of pain and what is paid it
seems as if pain is a hypothesis that
certain people bring to the table as the
best explanation for all of their
accepted interceptive fascinating you
said in the interview with us the first
time around that Evolution has blessed
us with phenomenal experience so we can
act autonomously and I wanted to know
and by the way um when you say
autonomous experience that there's this
technical term autopiosis which is the
ability to kind of like maintain
yourself and act autonomously and um and
and and you think this is this is the
crucial ingredient if you like but I
want to know what comes first does this
autonomy give rise to conscious
experience or does conscious experience
give rise to autonomy
they're different facets of the same
thing so the enact the auto poetic
inactivists championed by people like uh
Evan Thompson
uh talk about their Parable is the
parable of the Single Cell the Single
Cell the middle if you like
and they can describe that in Auto
poetic terms of a system which maintains
its own boundary conditions
it mentors its processes for keeping
itself alive precariously so at any one
moment the system might cease to exist
and it's this precariousness uh of
living that gives the the sort of the
theory goes it gives rise to the Proto
phenomenality and the sense of
normativity that the system will have
because it's important for the amoeba
whether it if it's in a sugar solution
then it moves up the sugar gradient and
not down the sugar grain if it is the
latter it will run out of energy and die
if it goes up the sugar grain it will
continue to live and so these simple
simple uh facts of interactions with the
environment so the inactivist the
autocratic inactive Story Goes what give
rise to Proto phenomenality and and a
sense of normativity of Engagement with
the environment
now
as I I've tried to make clear I mean
very interested in inactive with stories
I'm interested in embodied approaches to
cognitive science and activists and also
ecological approaches from people like
Gibson and um embedded theories of Mind
a whole range of topics that come under
the umbrella term the four e's
um but I'm not deeply committed to any
any of them these are just in these seem
to be interesting new approaches to
cognitive sites that have come around in
the last 10 to 20 years that are worthy
of of consideration
um uh and there to me the antidote to my
negative thinking about computationalism
because at one time it was people was
one of the reasons in my opinion people
were so committed to computationalism
particularly if they were of an
atheistic perspective is that if
computationalism doesn't work it
appeared that the only other game in
town was religion or mysterianism
and so it's really I think going in the
sort of after 10 or 20 years at
different approaches to mind have become
to be explored kind of quite seriously
and of which the inactively embodied the
ecologically embedded a ones that
interests me uh as you've been in
talking about David Chalmers he's very
famous for the extended theory of mind
which unlike many of my colleagues I
don't bracket together in the same way
as the the fouries that I mentioned
because it seems to me that David's
Chalmers and Andy Clark's extended a
theory of mine actually is just another
way of getting turing machine
functionalism or computationalism in
through the back door uh I I see it's
just a back door route to good
old-fashioned AI which is to me what the
other four is a kind of rebelling
against so I unlike many of my
colleagues I partition off Chalmers is
uh extended theories of Mind away from
the embodied the inactive the ecological
the extended top down the state of
cognitive science now how would
presumably there are
representationalists
it's important to to clarify that these
alternative approaches to cognitive
science are still probably minority
views if you took a a sample of all the
people who classify themselves as
cognitive scientists
um the majority would probably still
relate quite strongly to good
old-fashioned Ai and good old-fashioned
representational approaches to cognition
and cognitive science
um but then the four e's present a a an
alternative research program that does
have its own journals and scientists
working in the area and there is a
degree of momentum behind it but it's
still I would say a probably minority
view across all cognitive scientists
it's just one I've been obliged to take
seriously because I think there are good
a priori reasons for having skepticism
about any accounts that rely on
computation
so what are these four reviews well the
the embodied view is is
that began really with the work of
Rodney Brooks and Francisco Varela says
we need to take the role of the body
seriously and it looked at how systems
can interact without representation
by using the world for famously in
Romney Brooks's case as its own best
representation so that we began to see
the importance of taking I'm not looking
at the mind as somehow disembodied
which is what functionalists have always
seemed to me trying to do you know that
that approach
this is one of the big owners in in any
debate with Francois schweather he has
often said oh people who who don't take
this view uh must be some kind of
duelist where it seems to me that the
obverse is true people who are whole to
a computational view of the Mind have
some kind of strong deals to you because
for them the essence of the mind can be
expressed in an appropriate computer
program independent of the body whereas
whatever the hell I think the mind is
I'm pretty certain that when my body
ceases to exist well man ceases to exist
and that's the end of it so I uh
I I
my perspective I think are fairly
strongly
um suspicious of computational dualist
approaches to mind
the so the embodied approach takes the
body seriously uh it looks at how we can
interact with the world without
necessarily computationally manipulating
representations of it
and one of the ways it does that is by
positing using the world as its own best
representation
the inactive approach is an approach
that tries to explain
um sensation phenomenal sensation why
you see the color red when we see red
and not blue why I feel a particular
sensation as I drag my fingertips over
this leather and not the distinct
sensation of moving my fingers over
glass for example so why do I feel
leather when I move my fingers over
there and glass when I feel move my
fingers over glass and for the
inactivists it's to do with a sense
particular sensory motor contingencies
that are enacted when I perform both of
those operations that we learn over time
so it's the the enactment of that
gesture brings forth the sensation of uh
that I'm feeling
um and uh the most famous inactivists I
guess with people like in the
historically Francisco Varela Evan
Thompson we mentioned already
um people now uh like Ezekiel the Paolo
and Tom feroza and they they've
attempted to engage seriously and give
an explanation of how phenomenal
Consciousness can come about
so for the sensory motor and activists
and here I'm thinking of Alvin Noe Kevin
o Reagan from the University of Paris uh
they they are spouse a particular type
of inactivism that for example says that
with the character of a phenomenal
Excellence is is brought about our very
in engagement with the world
um to Auto poetic in activists like Evan
Thompson who
who attempt to answer questions about
how phenomenal it was is realized by
autonomous Auto poetic entities as they
engage with their environment
um the third type of school of approach
uh in cognitive science is relatively
modern although it's probably got an
older Heritage than many is is Gibson's
ecological approach to Vision which
talks about affordances
and and suggests that the way we enact
with the world is to do with the way
that objects afford certain actions so
very famously a cup the shape of a cup
affords picking it up in a certain way
and drink using it in a certain way and
that that looks at the role of the
environment and objects in the
environment and how these objects can
steer interactions with the objects
and finally the embedded notion of
cognitive science looks at how about how
cognition can is usually embedded within
a social Nexus of other cognitive agents
so we we're not Islands we're not we're
not all Islands we exist in a society
and how cognition can be in part social
and how our uh assault interactions can
give rise to cognitive States
so those are the approaches that I find
radical and interesting
that are not committed to computation at
their heart an attempt to give some
answers to the complex questions around
cognitive science I'm certainly not
committed to saying any I'm a firm
believer in any one of them I'm just
interested in them interesting but I
think there is there's a real theme
though in in what you're all about which
is the Primacy and importance of
phenomenal experience I think you
believe that it is impossible to have
any understanding you know you can't be
intelligence without phenomenal
experience and the thing that I want to
unpack is is this relationship between
autonomy and phenomenal experience I
know we were just saying which one came
first and to contrast with Chalmers
Chalmers doesn't think you need
phenomenal experience he has the thought
experiment of the philosophical zombie
um could you just kind of like sketch
that out a little bit
well David considers uh a doppelganger
Mark Bishop who speaks exactly the words
I would speak in any given context he
looks and behaves exactly like I do in
any given context except he has then My
Doppelganger has no inner mental life
David makes out there's nothing in the
physics of what we know about the world
that would rule out such it's a logical
possibility although interestingly in
his book The conscious mind if I'm
remember correctly David says that he
you know he doesn't believe such a thing
in our world uh
could exist so in in this Earth on this
Earth if an entity existed at exactly
the same as Mark Bishop then by what
David called the principles of
organizational invariance it would have
the same inner life as the real Mark
Bishop
but he says the fact that this is a
logical that we can have this is always
a logical possibility we can't rule it
out
um means that phenomenality is is not
logically entailed by by the physics of
the matter and then Dave for example
it's just an extra thing that we got to
bolt on and that leads David to what in
philosophical terms is called a a
property dualist approach to mind
interestingly Tom throwza in his latest
paper which I'll have to
read the title because it's a bit
long-winded eruption Theory a realist
framework for the efficiency of
conscious agency goes a Time further Tom
in this paper outlines how
the physics of what's going on in any
expandable situation is really all there
is
nonetheless and that's all we can ever
measure in any psychological or physical
experiment we can measure physical
values and they reflect the physical
state of the system under investigation
nevertheless Tom also takes seriously
the notion as reported by human subjects
of conscious agency I choose to raise my
finger or raise my arm
and the way that Tom reconciles these
two axioms which is seemingly in tension
with each other how can we have causal
Agency for the mind if the physics and
the measurable quantities are all there
are and they don't leave any uh back
door route for causation Tom Tom escapes
up by saying the systems are
underdetermined so conscious action
occurs
uh where uh as a degree of uncertainty
in a physical interaction increases so
the more uncertainty there is the more
the space there is for Consciousness to
intervene and exert causal Force
uh and we can measure that by look at
the entropy so Tom's proxy for
uncertainty is the entropy in these
situations so as entropy increases Tom
predicts uh that conscious engagement in
a particular experimental scenario will
increase and in the paper Tom points out
to various psychological experiments
that seem to measure and support that
thesis
and so this is a way so Tom doesn't give
any explanation as to how when we do
have high uncertainty how this thing
that he takes seriously called
Consciousness how that does affect
things it just says that is the space in
his theory gives a coherent space where
wherein that that can occur and into
that space you can slot your own
favorite Theory Of Consciousness whether
it's Professor Roger Penrose and Stuart
hamrov's Orca side reduction of The
Showdown uh uh the trilingual equation
or whether it's uh Carl friston's free
energy principle or whatever whatever
else you your favorite theory is you can
bolt that into the into the into the box
into this space where there's a high
degree of uncertainty of our
experimental condition that has the
benefit of taking conscious agencies
seriously whilst at the same time being
very grounded in the physics of
experimental measurements
if you don't mind um just to give a tiny
bit of a summary that there's a concept
we need to introduce here which is all
about this notion of mapping a
computation onto physical reality and
you um eloquently articulated the the
journey in in the first podcast episode
where you said all about touring
um came up with this abstract
computational formalism the discrete
State machine and demonstrated how you
could map
um computations to physical reality
um Putnam came along and said it was
possible to map computation to any open
physical system Chalmers came along and
said there was an exponential blow up if
you do so because the number of states
depends exponentially on the number of
the input space cardinality and he
introduced this um data structure called
a combinatorial state automator you then
came in and counted and said well
don't worry about that uh David Chalmers
because if you take a trace if you
record a trace of an episode then that
cardinality collapses and you you know
essentially what you've done is you've
got a finite state automata to represent
um an intelligent behavior and I think
the the theme of of your thinking is
this kind of like well let's let's
reduce everything down to its simplest
form when you were younger and worked at
reading you know how computers work at
the very lowest level they do what we
tell them to do so if you take a trace
of what is you know apparently an
intelligent action it then seems obvious
to you that it doesn't have a conscious
experience right
that's yeah in a nutshell
um the the essence of my response to
David is just to say well we'll observe
the system over a finite bounded window
and and that's axiom1 and Axiom two we
will know the inputs to that system
so when we know the inputs to a system
and we're observing it and measuring it
over a finite window we can absolutely
we can replace every one of the counter
factual
statements in the code with
non-counterfactual statements because we
know what the input is so if we have an
if in simple language if there's a line
of your code that says if a is greater
than 6 do X if it's less than six less
than or equal to six d y and we know the
the input is seven we can just go away
and so do X we can remove that branching
and that gets rid of Chalmers
combinatorial explosion because now all
we simply have is a simple linear series
of State transitions which must be
executed by that system over that time
window so
I run I've run this with Kevin said
right imagine you claim to me Kevin that
these cybernetic simple learning robots
are as conscious as a slug so they have
the same phenomenal conscious
experiences as a slow cooker his
arguments are there we'll see the same
number of neurons similar senses or
analogous solar sensory inputs they've
got the same mental life as I said I
said well okay well let's let's run
these robots for a minute in the Chorale
as they go around learning to move
around and not bump into things I'm
going to use a Data Logger to log all
the inputs of all the ultrasonic sensors
on the robots over that time period they
were sampling the environment that I
don't know 50 times a second for
argument's sake let's imagine so I just
logged all that data
so now I've got
your claim is over those 10 minutes of
learning time that the they were it was
something there was something it was
like to be one of your robots in fact
you said to me it was like being a
little slug the same sort of mental Life
as a slope okay so I'm now going to get
that robot I'm gonna imagine I'm gonna
be like a robot in a vat I'm now going
to disconnect the robot's real sensors
and actuators and feed the Rope what the
data that I previously logged
so the next step is what will the road
what field will it feel nothing
oh well it feel what it felt last time
and Kevin said well of course it was
getting exact the CPU is rating exactly
the same data getting out of exactly the
same data the state transitions in the
program are exactly the same
they'll feel the same
that's kind of interesting so no no and
what I'm now going to do is every line
of the program where you had a counter
factual statement I now know what the
input is so I'm going to one by one
delete those counterfactual statements
what's going to happen to the mental
life of your robot okay as well you know
the input's the same it's going to be
the same
interesting this is where David Chalmers
well I had this dialogue in in a back
and forth with papers with David in the
early 2000s differed he he said as soon
as you cut out
I see in in a program uh uh uh uh an if
statement even though you know given the
input it will always execute path a and
not path B
you're changing the system the possum
mere possibility for David of entering
into a different series of straight
transitions for David actually informs
the phenomenal character of the
experience and I as a hard-nosed
engineer I find that
extraordinarily bizarre what we're
seeing is if we delete one by one little
lines of code in your memory chip I
zaped them
that are never executed for David that
affects the phenomenal state of the
machine that
I find EX
extraordinarily difficult to take
seriously
um but that was his position then uh to
be fair to Kevin he didn't take that
view he said no no if you if you're
presenting the input and I know that
line of code's not been entered in
we'll just delete it and the Machine
will still have the same mental state if
we do that process enough we'll end up
with a single series of State
transitions the execution Trace if you
like which I can then map onto a simple
digital counter or after a Putnam showed
in his appendix to representation and
reality by using putting and mapping I
can map it onto any open physical system
so if it's the case that our Kevin
Wallace robot was conscious as it went
through that it was estate transitions
then any open physical system must be
conscious yeah that to me strike is very
implausible well it's it's I mean we'll
get to your dancing with Pixies reductio
again but um that does imply pan
psychism Which you think is abjectly
absurd not just pan sargism a
particularly vicious form of plant
sargism where any possible mental state
can be mapped onto any possible Thing by
virtue of using different mappings sure
sure but I would say the the the the
possibility that such a mapping exists
doesn't I mean I know you said that it
implies there's an infinitude of
conscious experiences all around us but
I think that that's that's a slightly
tenuous move
because it's quite it's quite a it's
quite a complex phenomenon that might
potentially map to the physical world
but I I wanted to get to this um thing
with Chalmers because unlike you
Chalmers doesn't think that
um phenomenal experience is requisite
for intelligence but but you do but
Chalmers thinks that a certain degree of
information processing complexity is
required for it to strongly emerge he
thinks that Consciousness is the only
strongly emergent property in the you
know phenomenon in the universe which is
to say that it's not directly deducible
from truths in the lower level domain
it's paradigmatically surprising it's
something it but but he's still a
materialist he's still a physicalist
which is really interesting yeah my
reading of the conscious mind was that
Consciousness exists in the universe as
we have more and more sophisticated
fine-grained functional organizations we
see Consciousness exercising more and
more sophisticated ways
such that if we rapidly carry to the
fine grain functional organization of
say my mind or your mind Tim and I'm
looking at a red square and I replicate
that fine grain functionalization in a
computer
then my phenomenal experience of the
Reds go out the computer will have
exactly the same phenomenal experience
because
for Chalmers the Consciousness is always
proto-consciousness is always there when
you build systems that have the same
fine-grown fruits and organization they
effectively emerge or Channel those
micro phenomenal experiences into one
larger coherent phenomenal experience
which in this case might be the
perception of a red square that's my
understanding of David and forgive me
David if I've paraphrased that
incorrectly but that's my understanding
of where he's coming from interesting
but but for Charmers
um this conscious experience is it
what's the cash value of it well exactly
I've never managed to work that out uh
and um
that contradicts human
first person accounts when I choose to
lift my hand up I'm electing to lift my
hand up that's a very interesting work
by Benjamin libbit on on on intention uh
which seems to rule at first to rule out
the role for conscience agency in in in
in deciding when to move around we can
look at Action potentials and when the
action potential was made to to move my
hand and all the rest of it there's some
very very bizarre work by Benjamin that
was very famous in the field
but I think all this is is neatly
circumscribed by Tom Fraser again in
this beautiful brand new paper in fact I
think he's still on the pre-print
service I'm not even certain it's been
published by the Journal at the moment
but uh to me Tom does in Tom's new work
he does take a Consciousness seriously
and he gives a space for it wherein
Consciousness can act and I don't think
that David's work does that it it's just
a property
of matter in certain configurations and
it seems to be happy phenomenal it has
no causal power of his own
um whereas for Tom's Theory Tom wants to
Grant conscious agency and I think
that's what's so exciting about Tom's
work to me yeah I think Chalmers would
say that
um this notion of top-down causation so
I think he would think that your your
conscious mind could allow you to raise
your hand which is
which is an example of a strongly
emergent phenomenon having having
control
um in your body which is in a lower
level domain but
um
I suppose could you argue that that
that's its utility
if that worked I've been very familiar
with top down and bottom but motives and
for many many years and I've yet to see
that cashed out it's one of those
philosophical hand-waving solutions that
I've seen talked about but I've yet to
see it demonstrated in any computational
system so people have talked about
having these computational systems where
lower level properties
a group together and then we have this
high level thing that's akin to human
consciousness that effectively exerts
control over what's going on at a lower
level and effectively then gives agency
to that top level conscious action I
haven't seen such systems exist in fact
what are my critiques of
computationalism is based around the
notion of teleology how goal orientated
Behavior exists because I see no way
that it can computationally the goal
direction is all engineered in by the
people who design these systems I see no
way of of systems having any teleology
of their own
um and and this this is the elephant in
the room that no one talks about one of
the many elephants in the room with AI
that people don't talk about where does
agency come in because I don't see any
computational explanation for agency at
all that's great but that then just says
there is no meaning I mean this is where
I'm driving with this point there is no
inherent semantics in that code it's
whatever we as users use it to be so
when we have the Chinese room program
there's no inherent semantics to sell so
it's all syntax and no semantics
although related we can recanted from
that position and said there isn't even
any syntax in in computer programs
that's a separate story which also
relates to dancing with Pixie producer
who has as it happens if you look up
cells wall you'll see why
um
uh but yeah there's no meaning in the
system there is no understanding there's
nothing but you know that I generalize
effectively what I'm saying with the
game I saw some generalizes the Chinese
room you know not only is there no
understanding in the Chinese room which
is a particular program designed to try
and understand Chinese stories there's
no inherent meaning in any program all
they are were engineered tools to do
things that make sense in a particular
human context the meaning the Vikings
said of this of language that there is
you know to say that uh
wow that's really cool and showing my
age as a child of the 60s or or that's
really bad I guess dates me from the 90s
when I mean really good I wouldn't even
know what kids are saying these days the
weather inverting the everyday use of a
linguistic term but this is a common
Trope that we see repeated time and time
again in teenage development throughout
the generations they'll turn a phrase
and invert it uh so there's no inherent
meaning to that it's the way that the
meaning is put to
yeah that gives it is the contacts with
and the use of the language the
particular language game that gives it
its meaning yeah so the it's a black uh
it's not uncommon uh I used to knock
around with some black geezers and it's
not uncommon for them to use the n-word
and have a particular in quotes meaning
they've titled subvert the meaning that
white people are typically used for that
you know in a way that if I was to use
that when you it would it would a very
different effect even if I wanted it to
be non-offensive it would still have
that offensive meaning to most people
yeah so you know the different language
game users can can bring forth different
meanings well if it can sign again
address this in philosophical
investigations what's famously called
the private language argument so he he
argues that it's incoherent for one
person to prevent the private language
I can't remember the the subtleties of
his argument but the the the superficial
uh uh description of it basically is
because we can't on your own have
conditions for successful use one day I
might call a spongy an elephant and the
next day another spongy and the next
thing I might call my speaker a sponge
it and because there's no external
criteria for when I'm using it correctly
because nobody else knows my language
you know it is the notion of life itself
gets incoherent because what do I mean
by Sponge it on Monday I happened to
call my vape the Swansea on Tuesday the
speaker
what what is a sponge because no one
else knows it and I don't know it either
because I mean it's indifferent there's
no criteria for when you're using terms
correctly when there's only a private
lands that's my very bastardized
superficial take on the planet language
so uh this is Mr Robbie
what have you got there you're gonna
you're gonna dip it into your coffee
mate I'm not really uh I'd say well this
looks over this looks too beautifully
baked to be dipped just me it's like you
get the cheap ones look like they absorb
this has got quite a strong pardoned
helicopter
it won't be as absorbent it's a
masterpiece isn't it yeah would you
think that
um cookies are a form of ad
well what not this one yeah I mean I
guess my point is it is there any
representation or is it aesthetic well
well the cookie or the way it looks for
the whole thing oh the whole thing see
this is more of a science well no but as
you know from a Wittgenstein point of
view it's in its use as well well yeah
so let's separate the aesthetic from um
how it's used do you think do you think
it's ours
um
I do actually yeah although in in a
subjective sense everything is on
because everything else is aesthetic and
you're after first do you think do you
think there's a discernible difference
well this is desirable defining the
difference between Art and Science as
far as it can every single science be
considered an art in some way and vice
versa it was really pleasing so I'm
painting now take a picture I go on what
I'm feeling I'm trying to recreate the
image that's R yes but
I'm approaching it scientifically
yeah I'm doing it in particular order do
you get what I mean there's a science
behind what works the light hits the
color the pigmentations of various
things in the same light not for an
artistic feel but because I need that
same light I always the colors are
different yeah yeah then again take a
science take take Einstein's theory of
relativity it might take 10 years to
come up with a mathematical nonsense but
the bit that he was interested in was an
artistic flash yes a non-scientifically
derived moment of inspiration yes but
you're getting into Free Will and
intentionality and also subjectivity you
always get the interest
and the thing is I actually think is the
distinction without a difference a lot
of objectivity is just it's just how we
formalize
um and reduce the essence of a complex
system yeah it's funny you say that I do
think is that where I was the way I was
approaching that was that the difference
in Art and Science in that respects
exists more as useful tool to
communicate than anything real yeah we
should go back to Victoria again that's
what he meant but words don't have
subject matter yeah so they just they
can just they don't have content no they
can refer to moves in the game yes and
they can and the moves in the game are
derived from the responses of the player
there's always like throwing out words
and killed killed Athens yellow green
okay well yeah they're all words but
it's like me playing chess and go right
my mood's going to be my horses are
coming up together you know you can't do
that in chess that's not part of the
rules yeah you can do it yeah you think
you can perform the action
not within this rule-based system well
he it is a philosophical investigations
and sinful it seems to refer to maths
yeah being the one thing that's
purely discoverable yeah as opposed to
definable yeah he thinks that there's an
inherent understanding of order
mathematical order so we understand ABC
because it's one two three I mean that
order if you kept rearranging the number
the letters of the um alphabet or they
didn't have a fixed order we wouldn't be
able to learn them yeah he writes in a
a friendly manner but a purposefully
critical match do you know what I mean
it's like very ambiguous and he's saying
that I'm not convinced he is but then
again if you read any forums about
people discussing liechtenstein's
particularly the philosophical
investigations there is no Universal
acceptance of what you're saying you
know they take one word one sentence and
argue with like six months yeah so I'm
not sure if there's a part of the
kushdie with a sort of cynical grin to
himself
you know amazing amazing
the point of the Chinese room argument
as understood by most functionalists is
that complex systems can exhibit
intelligent seeming Behavior even if the
individual components of the system are
not themselves intelligent
now this is because the behavior emerges
from the interaction between the
components rather than from any
individual component
but for this to work a real intelligence
is needed either as a component in the
system or in the case of the Chinese Rim
argument previously crystallized by an
actual intelligent person or process
but Dr Walid supper has a different take
entirely in a 2020 blog post describing
a story of chess players to analogize
the Chinese room argument he said that a
person who doesn't know how to play
chess can beat a grand master by playing
them indirectly and it's possible to do
so by observing the first move made by
the Grand Master and then making the
same move on the other Grand masters
board this of course will play the two
grand Masters against each other and the
person in the middle doesn't need to
understand anything about how to play
chess but they'll still end up beating
one of the grand Masters
the syntax of a language is the set of
rules which govern how a language can be
correctly structured the semantics of a
language is the meaning that is conveyed
by the language
in a programming language the syntax
might dictate that all variables must be
declared before they can be used
the semantics would dictate what the
variables represented
in natural language the syntax might
dictate that all sentences must have a
verb and a subject
the semantics would dictate what the
subject and verb represented
now Wally points out that in his view
understanding is the ability to create a
successful semantic mapping to the
original intentional structure
maintaining the constituents until the
last possible moment which would thus
allow us to handle an infinite set of
possible expressions
this is the difference between storing
the structure of three times four plus
six versus just the answer in a hash
table
while it proposes that keeping the
structure of the expression as a
first-class citizen in our semantic
mappings is the key to using
compositionality to overcome the
infinite cardinality of natural language
now this is what foda and volition
called systematicity in their Landmark
1988 critique of connectionism which is
a paper that we discussed on the Chomsky
show so go and check it out
Jerry foda hypothesized that thought is
structured in much the same way as
language he said that thoughts have
semantics a combinatorial syntax and
they store information symbolically
according to this hypothesis a thought's
meaning comes from the thoughts that
it's made up of its Atomic constituents
and from the way that these thoughts are
combined its syntactic parts
systematicity or compositionality with
respect to linguistic capacity is that
the ability to produce or understand
some sentences is intrinsically
connected to the ability to produce or
understand others photo and volition
considers systematicity to be a
pervasive feature of human thought and
not just on language
if you understand the sentence Mary
loves John then you understand the
sentence John loves Mary
now connectionists on the other hand
including our friend David Chalmers it's
actually ridiculous his name comes up
literally everywhere I don't think
there's a single
um area of philosophy and Linguistics
and AI that he hasn't had his hands all
over but anyway people like Chalmers
have argued that it is possible to
explain systematicity in the
productivity of thought which is to say
it's infinite nature using so-called
eliminative connectionist models he
described using distributed
representation so from a artificial
neural network
transform sentences from their active
form to their passive form but that's
another topic for another day anyway
Walid believes that interpretation
cannot be dictionary based like it is in
neural networks but it must be a system
which can leverage combinatorial
recursive and compositional semantics so
as to cover an infinite set of possible
expressions
now while it says that the compilers in
C plus and python already do this right
he thinks that if connectionism can only
do associative semantics or dictionary
semantics it's by no means an indictment
of the possibility that a compiler for
natural language can one day be built in
that regard he said he wholeheartedly
believes with what Richard Montague
stated a few decades ago Montague said
that there is in his opinion no
important theoretical difference between
natural languages and formal languages
indeed he considered it possible to
comprehend the syntax and semantics of
both kinds of languages with a single
natural and mathematically precise
Theory
Wally went one step further he said that
of course what Montague stated is
trivially true if one also believes what
a manual can't said nearly two decades
before
Kant said that everything in nature both
in the inanimate and the animate World
takes place according to rules although
we're not always acquainted with these
rules
what he believes that we will one day
figure out the logic which would allow
machines to understand natural language
but just to clear up any confusion we
still have the minor matter of
pragmatics to deal with even if such a
compiler exists for a natural language
it would only produce a semantic
potential we still have a huge inference
Gap to understand what was meant by the
thought behind a nutrients and as you
might imagine this would depend a lot on
contextual information common sense and
World Knowledge
but anyway um I think it's common to
confuse the Chinese room argument with
the Turing test I don't think so would
have given a monkey as if the rule book
was infinite and equally I don't think
he would have cared if the people
outside the room asking the questions
had no free will you know so their
questions were predetermined his point
was that sir in the room in lieu of
subjective experience could not have
possibly understood regardless of
whether people outside the room thought
he did
[Music]
so here's the problem
the trophy can be replaced by the laptop
by the ball by uh by my camera the
camera did not fit in and the suitcase
can be replaced by the closet by the
drawer by the trunk anything that I can
put stuff in yeah so this is a template
and and you can change did not with dig
and you can change although by because
and because by sense
so the combinations I can I can give you
uh in one second I can give you a
reasonable argument that says this
sentence is a template for 200 million
senses uh Chalet basically has this idea
of intelligence that
um you know if computers can generate
their own abstractions then then they
are intelligent and and you argue that
you know as as does so that
intentionality cannot exist within a
computational paradigm but many people
have said to me well um Tim what what
about
um what about open-endedness what about
some of the biologically inspired forms
of artificial intelligence this idea
that rather than giving them one
objective you have a planner play of
objectives and you can the system can
can kind of accumulate information and
create its own objectives and they would
say why is that not a form of
intentionality
I'll give you an anecdote of my time
from running University we had a group
under cabin Warwick who doing research
in genetic algorithms at the time
and I remember these postgrads as
postcards certainly cybernetics
personals can be quite excitable based
bit like me I guess and uh one day this
group of persons came in with all right
we've got this machine this is back in
the day I mean these are trivial
examples and I've only underground
probably do them at school without
imagine I don't know I'll kindergarten
back in the day we thought this was
exciting we trained the these guys got a
evolutionary system to to involve
walking gates for for a for a
quadrupedal robot
that's one whoa look at that I love they
said I'd love to show these uh these uh
um intelligent design people this here
we have a machine that for itself has
learned to walk and we don't need God we
don't need an entire designer
and I'm thinking Hmm let's have a look
at your program so I looked at that
program I looked at the The evolutionary
album and they engineered
the fitness function so inevitable it
was going to end up with a walking gauge
it couldn't have done anything else it
might take it a bloody long time 10
years a week I don't know but it was
going to get there it couldn't do
anything else in other words the
teleology had been engineered into it by
its designers
I I first want to talk a little bit
about
um behaviorism again which is something
rampant in in the AI community and I
think the issue boils down in in large
part to the triviality and
incompleteness of imitation right so in
sales view a digital computer or
comparable system would not fully learn
Chinese by blindly following the
commands of a computer program meant to
simulate the behavior of a Chinese
speaker so this is probably why you
believe that gpt3 is a fake replica of
comprehension right so what would you
respond to those who contend that the
line between imitation and genuine
understanding is blurring
that they're very misguided people
um
this is something that again there's so
many answers about the Chinese room
thought experiment so uh anticipates and
describes in his paper and
unfortunately the cro the Chinese
argument is is like in one of a group of
papers in philosophy and computer
science that everybody has an opinion of
but not everybody has read or at least
not read carefully so for example
everybody thinks they know what the
Turing test is and I'd be very surprised
if more than one in 10 have got much of
an idea what Turing actually wrote
everybody thinks they know what sells
Chinese rumors everybody thinks they
know what Roger Penrose is saying and
yet famously very few people actually
engage with Source material on these
packs so for example
um
so in the paper very carefully considers
the difference between the simulation of
a thing and the thing itself this is an
ontological difference
and it's a difference in kind in other
words
um and so says you know the simulation I
can build if I'm so inclined and no
biology a really detailed simulation of
a Carol lactating
but I won't be able to drink any milk as
a result
I can simulate if I'm so inclined the
properties of gold but I can't then go
out and buy myself a yacht like Elon
Musk has got or funded space expedition
to Miles like he's doing
um
I could simulate from a meteorologist I
can see me the weather for a store but
that simulation won't make me wet
there's a fundamental ontological
difference between the simulation of a
thing and the thing it's the difference
between epistemology and ontology so
epistemology acts allows us to ask
questions how would I
quiz you if I want to know you
understand something I would if I want
to know if you understand uh uh
differentiation I might ask you a
certain set of questions about how to
differentiate x squared for argument
sake or 3x squared or whatever and if
you go over convincingly go appropriate
answers I might think on probably Tim
has got this concept
so that's epistemologically how I might
try to a certain whether you've got some
understanding of that but that's not
replicating the understanding for myself
so that's a question of knowledge
epistemology is asking us questions of
knowledge about how I can know something
about something else it's not addressing
questions and being
and this is what the Chinese room so
beautifully illustrates
um so we can ask put to the Chinese room
questions that if I was to put them to a
genuine human and they answered
appropriately
and that's only otherwise I would tend
to think that that person knew Chinese
I might be misguided it might be that
that person was absolutely running a
Chinese room program in their head and
they didn't have a clue what on Earth I
was saying but as a first approximation
I'd be tempted to to accredit them with
that with that
um
but it wouldn't be it we're still not
bringing about that mental state in
ourselves we're just testing for it is
and so I think there's a fundamental
difference in kind between the
simulation of a thing and the thing
unless
that simulation gets to be so
fine-grained it is a duplication so if I
simulate with all the causal Powers
every molecule and atom an electron of
gold
in other words I've duplicated goals
I've actually got gold in front of me
and then I haven't got a problem so but
you we want to get all the causal powers
of a system if we duplicate it right the
way down to the bottom and if that that
then raises the questions of if such a
duplication is even physically possible
this is Professor gnome Chomsky uh what
Larkin you know and Galileo are
comprehensive really understand how
these mysterious properties work instead
of being mystified by the fact that you
know I can move the Moon by putting my
hand as we are of course all right but
they're just two separate issues and
Churchill is just missing the point
there's a conceptual distinction then
there's an empirical question of what
lies within these domains select take
particular cases like C
consciousness
we have no idea maybe it'll turn out to
be like as like motion we'll be able to
develop theory of it but it won't be uh
but but we won't be able to conceive of
how the theory works so it's like the
fact that I can't conceive of the fact
that when you take a drive of water or a
new it's an electric current through it
it ends up as two gases I know it
happens because I learned in the
chemistry course but I don't have the
kind of conception of it that Galileo
and Newton and the founders of modern
science aimed for it and we've given up
that hope doesn't matter what we can
conceive of anymore that we accept
what the best theoretical explanations
give us and it may turn out very likely
will turn out that the uh that the
priestley's approach to Consciousness
namely discover try to discover the
organic structures that yield these
phenomena maybe that will yield the
result like Newton's theory of motion uh
explanatory Theory but not one we can
consume the now Consciousness is called
the hard problem
in the 18th century 17th century motion
was called the heart problem in fact the
same terms were used It's the Hard Rock
for philosophies it's a really pediate
different mutants and the reason is that
mosh just with lock said uh motion has
properties that we cannot conceive of
which is correct but uh so we've given
up the hope of conceiving of them and
just you know develop theories of motion
and Hume for example described Newton's
greatest contribution as uh
demonstrating that there are Mysteries
his term which the human mind will never
penetrate
and he meant the mysteries of motion
those Mysteries were never solved they
were abandoned as science just took them
were
a less ambitious course aiming for
intelligible theories rather than
comprehending Mysteries which by their
very nature we can't comprehend
uh that's all that's humor already
syntax is not sufficient for human
thought at least according to Professor
9 Chomsky but he does think that we
think in syntax
now Chomsky has no idea whether or not
the universe is computable it leaves us
with more questions than answers can a
finite number of symbols be used to
represent everything that can be known
semantically can they be composed in any
way to represent everything that you
know he considers all of us to be little
more than touring machines with the
belief that all thought is expressed in
a universally applicable grammar
Chomsky also discusses the issue of
differential semantics whereas in for
example flying may be referred to as
hopping in certain regions
now this only serves to increase the
necessary syntactical burden Chomsky is
willing to consider the idea that we
might not be able to comprehend
everything he remarked that it would be
well it would take a miracle if every
ontological truth could be expressed in
words
when discussing the limits of the human
mind he frequently refers to the
inability of rats to complete a maze
based on prime numbers
it's possible that a turing machine
could express realities that people have
trouble describing in syntactic language
while humans May struggle to make sense
of truths that can be represented
semantically computers may be able to
now there are ideas which defy
encapsulation in words like Free Will
which many people fervently believe
exists but there's also a cognitive and
resource Horizon perhaps we might codify
an algorithm to determine what a pile of
sand is or how it feels to be burned but
the resulting code will either be
unintelligible or would take an
unlimited amount of syntax or execution
time does it require aixi infinite
computation or is there a practical hope
even if the universe is computable
there's clearly no practical manner in
which we can compute what we need to
right we're always going to be working
on approximations which may be
sufficient for some things but not
others if the rouliad of the Mind was
finite and Beyond like cognitive
comprehension that doesn't necessarily
mean that it would be beyond the
cognitive Horizon of an artificial
intelligence or a civilization of people
augmented by technology it's often
assumed that if humans could understand
something it would be unambiguous
however this is not necessarily the case
there are many possible mathematical
descriptions of reality in some cases
infinitely many
is it possible for understanding to be
ambiguous if there are multiple possible
descriptions it's not clear that we can
say that we understand the thing in
question this is what Eric curiel points
out and we played a clip from him on the
Chomsky show
now he makes an interesting case which
is suppose that humans could understand
the syntax and it was finite and every
Behavior could be described by this
syntax be it math or logic or a turing
machine then there's the other problem
there are multiple possible mathematical
descriptions like for example the tensor
formulation of General general
relativity
so if you get different Stacks which are
all finite and describe the universe we
would understand the ones which we were
aware of but would also have to settle
for an ambiguous understanding
potentially at a lower resolution
now my intuition is that understanding
is a binary it can't be ambiguous but
that's just wrong right there's many
different ways of structuring the
mathematics a formula might be expressed
in different ways if mathematics gives
you a set of possible formulas it's not
that they're ambiguous per se they're
just multiple descriptions there's a
mismatch between what the mathematics
describes and what the universe is
there's a huge infinite World of
mathematical descriptions and then
there's all this stuff over here in
reality it's not clear that the
ontological truth is representable by
mathematics mathematics describes much
more than what is real maybe not
everything that is real in our universe
there's the set of all possible true
behaviors and then the set of everything
that mathematics describes and then the
intersection
now the thing in itself is a concept
introduced by the German philosopher
Emmanuel Kant according to Kant the
thing in itself is the true nature of an
object which is hidden from us by the
veil of perception
can't argue that we can never know the
thing in itself directly but we can know
about it indirectly through our Concepts
and ideas and indeed mathematics this is
an idea which has been very influential
and subsequent philosophical thought
okay so um we are here with Alexander
Matic who is officially the smartest
person in yannick's Discord and one of
my heroes
um Alex has got some really interesting
thoughts about syntax versus semantics
and it was just too delicious to leave
out of the show so
um Alex welcome to mlst and and what
have you got for us
so most of the problems with all of
these discussions especially when it
comes to like strong AI or general AI
boil down to Intelligence being
ill-defined in the first place but we
can look at the problem still from a
view of semantics because that
oftentimes give you gives you better
results
so
specifically one of the problems when
talking about semantics specifically is
also that different fields define
slightly differently while they still
talk about ultimately the same thing
they talk about
different views of the same problem so
for example if you ask a psychologist or
cognitive scientists of what semantics
are they're going to say well semantics
is just what's happening in our brains
this is ultimately true at least from a
human point of view but it's also not
really that actionable and ignores more
fine-grained foundational structure such
as why the brain even has a semantics of
it does
in logic AI or computer science we look
at specifically applied semantics that
means we want to Define meaning and then
do computations with that with that
defined meaning
so the syntax in that case is the made
explicit uh formal language so this is
the thing that contains formulas terms
sentences all that stuff
then we have a notion of Truth and
valency which is defined by mapping into
some context or world
and then we finally have a truth
preserving uh a truth preserving step
language which is the inference portion
the big problem with just looking at
syntactic part is that the syntax does
not uniquely determine the semantics
to give a concrete example you can look
at a very simple abstract data type like
the data type of natural numbers that
consists of a type 0 or which is just uh
like a value Z and a successor
relationship that just gives you the
success of that number so you start off
with zero and then you say the successor
and the successor and so on
and I can immediately give you a trivial
semantics of a data type and the idea is
simply well the semantics of this data
type is just
the identity function we just say well
the meaning of saying this is s of Z of
z s of s of s of Z is just s of s of s
of Z it doesn't tell you anything but
it's technically a semantic mapping
so
um
in practice we don't want these
so-called Hub Role Models they're very
useful for proofs but you can't really
do anything with them because it's just
a representation of the term tree
in practice what we want is we want to
go and write down a certain term like E
equals one half M times V squared
and then say well we don't only want to
have this term just stand there but we
want to do computations with them so we
want to say for example e m and V are
variables which we want to give a value
to
and we want to have reduction rules that
for example say well if we have M as a
value
and we multiplied by one half the value
inside m is half of that so we put in 8
and we get out four
so
um with that we can now ask the more
interesting questions so for example uh
given a selection of e m and V
does that relation hold so it's equality
relation
or on the other hand we can also ask
questions like
um
thus uh given a selection of M and V is
there some World in which e has a value
in the model satisfied which is what you
do when you solve an equation
essentially
so but then of course asks the question
of what are the correct reduction rules
and what is the correct context in that
case
and just as we look in the definition of
the natural numbers I gave before it's
not uniquely determined just like we
could here say we have the same
hairbrush structure which says we have
no reduction rules it just is what it is
or we could again say let's choose a
nonsensical interpretation let's say
it's a equals B is always true regards
what you put in
there is nothing from a syntactic point
of view that tells you that this is
wrong or this is right
and to give a more extreme practical
example let's assume the normal
reduction rules of arithmetic applies
and we set
e to minus 100 V to 5 and then ask the
question of whether there's a model
where M has a value
using kind of the standards arithmetic
manipulations we can come to the result
that m equals minus eight
so obviously now there exists a model
and precisely one model which is the one
which has m equals minus eight
but if you went to your high school
physics teacher and gave him well I've
figured out m is equal to minus eight it
was so Bonk you because now you've
presented a solution which has negative
Mass
so even though we have found a
definition in this case it's still wrong
because the the definition does not
align with the semantics that we
actually want
now you could go and could say well
let's take this constraint that M has to
be bigger than 0 and reify it so put it
explicitly into the model
that would look like we have instead of
just having E equals one half M times V
squared we have E equals one half times
M times times V squared and M is bigger
than zero
but now we've just invented two new
things bigger than and and which we have
to give a meaning to
of course we can also go and we can try
to give that a meaning but at some point
if we Define something recursively again
and again and again we are going to have
to reach the bottom of the induction
tree
and semantics now is how do we set the
bottom of that induction tree such that
we get this true preserving relation in
some useful context so something like
physics math natural language whatever
semantics is about what assumptions do
you make on the ground floor and how do
you propagate them further
so you can listen for example through
the Chinese room as much as you want
and you can get a 100 accurate mapping
from input to Output but you're still
going to know what is actually happening
in there because
you don't know what the underlying
semantics are because it's not in the
syntax the syntax doesn't give you
enough
so to get useful Protections in any case
you can't assume you have role model you
have to assume some other model which
you probably go around and you test in
the real world
and that's then the entire field of
epistemology where you basically try to
formalize what it means to have a
specific semantics and specific
structure and test it in the real world
yeah that's so interesting I mean um we
were talking on the intro about Eric
curio I think we've spoken about him
with with Keith and he says that there
are many
um descriptions many mathematical
descriptions for for reality because you
can think of mathematics as
um you know kind of covering this huge
abstraction space and and much of the
abstraction space Bears no resemblance
whatsoever to to reality and there's
kind of an intersection between what's
mathematically describable and reality
but he also says that there's ambiguous
um descriptions because what does it
mean to understand I mean if you if you
actually have two or more descriptions
and that's my way of understanding the
world that we live in does that mean
that I don't really understand the
complicated part about the Sim text and
semantics discussion is that really the
interesting part is always the semantics
because that's was actually real world
we may never actually get to that but
the semantics are the important part so
for example in physics
even though it's a useful way of
thinking about it there is nothing that
forces the existence of for example
complex numbers in the physical world
it's a useful abstraction that gives you
a nice syntax semantics pairing so but
the idea is we can take a physical
process we can move it down into the
semantic sphere which then may be able
to use things like complex numbers at
any point we can then take it and put it
back into the real world
and that's the powerful thing because
really as long as this connection is
upheld we don't care about what we do
syntactically so we can use Newtonian
lagrangian hamiltonian Dynamics all of
which complete convert completely
differently on a syntactic level it is
still Transit into the same semantic
result
so the important part is the connection
between syntax and semantics and not
what style of syntax we prefer or how we
implement it that's it partly the the
problem is when John John so talks about
um you know his his paper brains minds
and and machines he talks about the
difference between
um you know what what is um an
ontological description and epistemic
and he talks about the difference
between what is objective and what is
subjective and combinations of of the
two so is that partially the explanation
why
um there is this there is this difficult
mapping between syntax and semantics
because basically we we create the
syntax definitely we we just invent the
syntax we just make it up but I think
that the problem more with analyzing
things like economics or language from a
purely semantic point of view is because
these models we we want to study them a
lot more in the real world directly and
we have very very poor languages to talk
about uh these kind of things
syntactically it means that the
semantics of something like natural
language or economics is way way harder
to grasp than the semantics of an object
moving through space
it's not that there is no semantics it's
just that it's a lot harder to actually
grasp because the models or the
languages we have don't map well to the
semantics that occur in the real world
that's why one of the first things in
for example computer programming what we
get rid of in like these formal
languages what we have in real languages
are things like
um like anaphora where we have
implicitly referred something or we have
homonyms where they're two different
things with two different words refer to
different things even though they have
the same uh kind of syntactic Nature and
that's what makes semantics for natural
language very difficult because
the the semantics of very not nice
they're very very complicated which also
makes them very very interesting from a
theoretical point of view but
ultimately I don't think that there is
really that big of a distinction between
having these uh like these objective
structures they have any subjective
structures such as subjective structures
because of their emerging properties are
oftentimes a lot more complex so in In
classical Linguistics you have this kind
of this waterfall model where first you
have the the speaking and basically the
parising of spoken language then you
have okay we take this and we parse it
into often some kind of tree structure
or something else and then we can kind
of process these along and this
structure is not really true because you
have to to get the tree oftentimes you
already need to kind of analyze kind of
the that you have to do pragmatic
analysis of what is actually in it so I
don't think that the this waterfall
model is true but I also don't think
that you can go and say whether that
English can really be treated as kind of
a syntactical formal language that's
it's it's it's hard to describe or how
to give a reason for it but it's much
more likely of at least to me that the
kind of the idea of Montague where he
said that he published a paper called
English as a formal language where the
idea was not to literally treat English
as a form language but to say well we
can take English take uh fragments of it
and transport it into a formal language
and then we can do like the the normal
logical reasoning there it doesn't mean
that English itself is a formal language
but it means that we can Trend we can
transform into a formal language which
is slightly different and I think that's
much more realistic
yeah I I admire Montague's ambition
um just uh in in closing and on on this
paper from Seoul and he was kind of
making this argument that
um there's there's a difference in being
when when when you understand something
as a human being so when when I tell you
a joke and and you laugh you you have
that that Sensation that subjective
experience which has semantic valence
and that's the reason why they could be
no computer program to represent Alex I
mean would you would you agree with that
intuitively I mean ultimately I don't
think that that's really true
just because of
um techniques or something like humor
often uh has it has some reason why it
exists so you can for example make the
argument where it's it's some kind of
surprise reaction and you could model
this by saying well we have some context
and we act inside that context and the
semantics are also described but also
including the context similar to the
example I gave with the the speed uh the
kinetic energy equation where you just
need to set the right values and you
would get the same results now don't
really see a reason why this wouldn't be
the case for uh something like language
I think
it is the case that these kind of things
become harder and harder to track at
some point because the kind of the the
context becomes way too large but I
don't think that there's something
that's fundamentally different in uh how
we would process something like a
language and how we process something
like physics it's just it just may be
more complicated
but not really materially different
interesting yeah I mean I I think the um
the argument that so would put forward
is is that sensation is a physical
property so it's not it's something that
couldn't be created in the virtual
information world you know like for
example you can simulate something
burning but it wouldn't actually be
burning because it's this virtual
information simulacrum thing
in but that's exactly where we have a
syntax semantics uh view comes in get
some tactically burning a log is
different than simulating burning a log
but the the actual semantic nature that
you extract from it that might be
exactly the same so
let's not go into that too deeply but
even if kind of the real world would be
a simulation that wouldn't change
anything about the log burning in your
experience and your semantic content you
get from the log burning even if kind of
the the foundational structure of the
world is completely different than you
would expect that doesn't change the
semantic structure you obtain from there
but if if there were an ontological
difference between these the physical
sensation of of of burning or being wet
and the simulation of it would you then
accept that there was a difference
I mean if things are different then yes
it would ex I would accept that things
are different I just don't see a reason
for
I don't really see an argument for why
that would be the case specifically
because if the the idea for syntax
semantics is that the the thing
happening in the real world and the
representation is a mapping and there is
no reason why you couldn't go and if you
you have something assimilation you just
change the mapping to be the equivalent
notion so you you don't have to be have
the exact same structure you just have
to have something that is equivalent to
it you have to have that something be
translatable into different forms just
like I can talk to you in English about
a concept and then construct you about
the same concept in German and it's the
same thing it just is it involves a lot
of translation but really I can express
the exact same content in both languages
or I can ex I can talk about the same
thing using neutronium and lagrangian
Dynamics it's it's the exact same things
there's different structures and
different languages to use that
interesting I mean we spoke a bit about
this that the understanding is that as a
successful semantic mapping and
um
you have to map to something so so I
guess you could make the argument that
if you didn't actually have that quality
or that subjective sensation then in in
silico in simulation there'd be nothing
to map to
that goes closer to the point but
so you're you're going to have to have a
Target your map to that is that is
exactly what's making something like
semantic analysis of language difficult
because we don't know what to map to so
for example one of the first ideas I had
talked about this uh a couple of days
ago in on yesterday actually here on
Discord
um where because the initial ideas about
Linguistics have things like the idea of
okay we have sets of objects and if we
talk about a car we talk about this set
of all cars and we talk about blue then
we have the set of all blue things and
we talk about the blue car we have the
we have the intersection of a blue of
blueness and currentness and
intersection of that is the set of that
for the practice if you try to do that
kind of more rigorously and you continue
it you get something like a large car
and you have kind of the the set of cars
and you have the set of largeness
which what is a large car a large car is
the a pretty small house so there is no
set of large things
so we don't we can't map it to uh to
sets so when people start people start
to go into something like fuzzy logic
and try to go with that and that turns
out to to kind of maybe work because
they have the problem of this this
subjectiveness and people went and said
well let's view
um
uh that it's a few sides just like a
transformation so you have like a car
object and and saying a large car is
just a transformation of that
and kind of it goes from there but we
don't really have an answer of what
something would amount to an even more
extreme example is that the word not it
can have uh or a basic indication if I
have if I say I am in a car you can kind
of say okay I have the concept of being
and I have the concept of car and you
could combine them they would say I'm
not in a car then you you have the the
concept of being and you have the
concept of car and you have the negation
which is everything but being in the car
so it's it's negation of the set and you
can see how things become go very out of
hand very quickly
it that that doesn't mean it's a useful
process it's a useless process it's it's
just about it's a scientific process
it's the the question about syntax and
semantics oftentimes also boils down to
that the question of do you just care
about something like predicting the next
token which can do configuration
tactically nobody is kind of doubting
that or going more which is basically
engineering view or you go into a more
scientific View and ask okay the next
token would be hot but why is a thoughts
what makes the next token be hot
and that then goes down the rabbit of
okay we need to figure out what that's
supposed to even mean and that goes this
syntax semantic problem
amazing well Alex thank you very much
indeed and folks can catch Alex on
yannick's Discord and occasionally on
our Discord but mostly on yannick's
Discord and it's absolute pleasure thank
you so much